but i also did pick up a tip
that
i applied to myself and it really worked
for me as i was watching an interview
with taika watiti actually and he was
talking about his writing process
how often have you been afraid to finish
a screenplay
all the time
like i feel like with every screenplay
you know you're always
i feel like there's always stages you go
through at least for me this is my
experience going through a screenplay
and usually it's like you have an idea
and you're very excited about it and you
start to put it all together and and
you're thinking yeah this this could
actually be good you've convinced
yourself that's going to be good
and then you start to write it and when
you start to write it it's really
exciting because you're like oh it's
finally happening and i'm setting things
up and you know i got this character in
here and i'm i'm getting it getting it
going
uh and then you know when you get to the
end of the screenplay you're also very
excited because you're like oh i'm so
close to the finish line oh like this is
this is great uh but you know in the
middle when you're in that middle slog
of getting through a screenplay
uh that's the point when you're start to
think like uh like i don't know is this
idea actually that good like i'm not
sure if this is working the way that i
intended it to work
and that's when you can start to have
those fears of like
maybe not wanting to finish something uh
or feeling like uh you know i think
maybe this isn't gonna be
worth the rest of my time to finish so
uh for me personally i think everything
i write i usually go through that like
you know experience or usually go
through that uh that doubt uh but but i
always try to remind myself to like you
know trust the process a little bit and
think you know there's a reason why you
were excited about this there's a reason
why you just start you decided to start
this at one point you know a couple
months ago you felt like this was an
amazing idea
so just you know trust the process you
know just keep going get to the end and
um and you know hopefully when you do
finish it and you read it back you'll
you'll get excited about it again so
um but yeah back to your question uh i
think all the time i'm always like
fearful of finishing a script because
i'm always like oh is this thing going
to be bad
with the wrestling script that you had
option with your partner was there a
moment where were there times when the
two of you didn't feel like was it
really worth it
uh yeah there were there were
times where i was like oh i don't really
know if it was working or or not but
um maybe that one was a little bit
different because
that one we were together so
you have someone to kind of constantly
talk talk it through but other scripts
that i've written um
are those ones are the ones where it's
like yeah you only have that internal
conversation with yourself so those are
the ones that are
sometimes that can be a little harder to
push through
are there unfinished screenplays at your
house uh
there
there's two types of unfinished
screenplays there's the unfinished
screenplays that
uh i started way early in my career when
i just started writing and and didn't
really know what i was doing so there's
those and then there's the ones that i'm
currently working on
that are unfinished but they will be
finished so
um i think now i'm at the point where if
i really do start to write something um
i definitely will finish it um so
i've kind of tricked myself into into
getting into the routine of of making
sure that i get across that finish line
what do you find time to write since
you're doing these music videos is it
between each project i know we've had
some time off with the current pandemic
but yeah yeah i think
writing is just something that i've just
kind of built into my schedule um
it's something i just try to do
a few times a week i mean if i'm if i'm
busy if i'm directing something or i'm
on a project like you know the week gets
away from myself and yeah i don't i
don't
i don't get mad if i can't write that
day it's okay
but typically you know if i have a day
off um i'm definitely in the morning
writing for a few hours every day
so it's just something i kind of just
build into my routine
what does the inner dialogue sound like
when doubt creeps in
about finishing a screenplay oh it
sounds like oh this is you know all the
things this is terrible
uh this this this is not working
uh you know this idea is really stupid
you know you can say all those things uh
as you're writing and working on
something and feeling like
well like why am i spending my time
writing this thing like no one's gonna
read this or you know it's it won't be
made or whatever it is
um
but
you know they're they're just they're
just voices they're just it's just noise
um
so you have to always kind of battle
through that uh and you know if you're
really struggling with something you can
always get you know people to read it or
you can talk to your friends or whoever
about you know the idea and usually
you'll get back you know
positive feedback uh
or if you or if you're getting if you
think your your script is going astray
or it's not working you can talk talk to
people about it and if it actually is
doing pretty good and you're just kind
of creating this own you know self-doubt
in your head
you'll get realigned by your friends who
are like no no this is pretty good so
far or like maybe they'll read the first
you know whatever first act and they're
like nah i really enjoyed it and so that
that positive feedback can help sort of
reset you
can you talk about a time when fear won
out and you did not finish the
screenplay i think that there has been
times that
yeah i think i have had time for i'm
writing something and working on an idea
and
for whatever reason you know you just
get to a point where you you
maybe it's not fear necessarily you know
because i don't know if i'm like afraid
of the
potential of this idea or if it's that
i'm afraid of of this idea
not being
uh
well received but
but for whatever reason you're you might
be working on something you're just like
yeah i just i don't know i'm just not as
passionate about this screenplay as i
used to be um so so maybe it's not fear
specifically uh at least in the example
that i'm thinking of for myself
but
uh
yeah i don't know
is finishing things no matter what not
not just a screenplay is that something
that's always been instilled in you
i don't know if
i don't know if it's like necessarily
like an adage that i
subscribe to i think i've just probably
i don't know where i got it or i got
this sound bite but you know i've heard
someone say that it's like you know you
know anyone can start writing a book or
a screenplay or whatever but it takes
you know real dedication to finish
something
um
and
that's not to say that i'm like you know
the the pillar of that you know
platitude that you know i'm i'm i always
finish everything that i start but but i
i found that quote to be you know
inspiring to myself and so i'm like yeah
like that is true like it really does
take a lot of work to actually finish
something and
that alone kind of makes it worth doing
because not a lot of people can't uh sit
through it all the way so
i try to try to remind myself of that
from time to time as
i'm working if that's the thing that
helps motivate me to keep going then
i'll definitely
channel that idea
how did you develop your writing routine
it took a few years to figure out what
kind of worked for me
um i used to be someone who would just
power like you know do like eight nine
hour sessions and just keep going or i
would right in the middle of the night
because i felt like i was more creative
then or whatever it was
but over time to me i found that
um the most productive thing for me to
do was to
have it be scheduled at the same time
and to just do it for
you know three or four hours max because
after about three or four hours if i'm
actually
doing the work correctly um i'm pretty
spent after that like or i feel like
there's diminishing returns after a
while um
but i also did pick up a tip
that
i applied to myself and it really worked
for me as i was watching an interview
with taika watiti actually and he was
talking about his writing process uh and
he was being you know uh a reverend you
know towards himself and
self-deprecating is talking about how he
has add or whatever and he was like you
know what really helps him is that he
actually sets a timer on his desk um and
he writes in 20 minute windows so he
will do a timer that so like you have to
write for 20 minutes and there's no
internet there's no checking your phone
there's no whatever and then you get
five minutes after that 20 minutes and
you can do whatever you want you can
browse reddit you can go on youtube you
can go watch a film courage video
whatever you want to do
and then the clock goes back to 20
minutes and you got to write again and
then you can take another five minute
break
and i actually started doing that for
myself and it was super super effective
because
it just it just forces you
to
either stare at that blank page with a
cursor blinking or you or you have to
um
or or you just you know start typing
it's like you know because there's
always that instinct to like pick up
your phone when you don't know what's
right next or you know you're hung up on
a word or a sentence or a line of
dialogue
and you know it can become very easy to
tab over to a web browser and start you
know looking up cat videos but
when you have this feeling of a timer
that's telling you
this is your time to write and you're
not allowed to do anything else that
little added pressure uh is really
helpful for avoiding distractions
so that was something that he mentioned
that he did and
ever since i tried it out i've
definitely built that into my routine
and it's worked really well
was that his ted talk
uh you know it might have been okay i'm
not really sure it was it was definitely
an interview of some kind that i
happened to catch
and maybe it was a ted talk or maybe it
was uh
just a
you know
talking
behind the scenes or a promotion for a
film that he did i'm not really sure
where it was that i saw that
it's interesting too because it almost
reminds me of how some of these tech
companies give people like an hour free
time
to be on the to to surf the net and just
just
so they don't feel like they have to be
stuck at their desk and i'm wondering if
we almost need that like because then we
feel too like okay this is a chore you
have to do this yeah actually that's a
great point because there is that
sensation of like you know we all do it
we all like go on whatever facebook or
instagram and you all kind of noodle
around while you're working and then
there's this feeling of a little bit of
a guilt that you're procrastinating um
but if if you have these windows these
time slots where it's like okay 20
minutes work and then now five minutes
you can do whatever you want you can
watch all the you know cat videos you
want in this five minute time it
actually is very freeing and you get you
know you give yourself that permission
to
procrastinate in that little window um
and yeah i i find it really helpful
you